what is one secret about this dress you
could tell one secret about this dress
uh it's really old
hivel Dior
you're giving us a gold moment and we
missed yet the Golden Globes but
everyone freaked out when we heard that
you're working on a musical and it was a
little uh they jumped the gun a little
too mysterious
I wanted to give
um
a bona fide explanation as to why I
missed it I didn't want that generic
can't be here tonight it was just like
no I can't be here for an incredible
reason the incredible reason is that I'm
you know living my life
fantasy you're literally making a
musical about Thelma and Louise with
Evan Rachel Wood I mean that is a pinch
me moment what do you want us to know
about it
uh that
that the creators are working diligently
to bring something
Beyond Comprehension to life onto the
stage you know it's so early days it was
just a very important week
and I still have all the music in my
head I can't stop singing it oh my gosh
um it's just a I can't I I don't know I
listen it's gonna be a while sure does
it add any pressure knowing how beloved
this movie is and especially the two
actresses behind the hell you know what
no no it just makes you more excited
because it's been a long time
and it Cali Corey who wrote it yeah is
is writing this so uh we've got we've
got all the right people involved I'm
not scared at all I'm just
um it's just new uh you know flock to
the great white way when that happened I
really hope I you know I just we got to
put some good vibes out to make sure you
know it takes a long time to create
something like you
I mean it takes a long time in fact
actually there's two other musicals I
want to ask you about Mean Girls the
musical is being adapted to film are you
gonna flock to the theaters for that too
yeah
I'm gonna flock sooner maybe oh are you
making a little cameo in the film I
don't know I don't know I I
truly honestly don't know for sure but I
I'm very open to it okay it must be
amazing to see it take on a new life
right in this way it's evolved so much
over over the years I mean it's still
one that was my first movie it was so
beloved and um and I'm just
I don't think I don't see it ever ending
I ever I hope it never stops evolving it
probably will
but uh what a what a good idea
uh Mamma Mia three everyone wants it
what do we got to do to make it happen
absolutely no power I have no power
would you jump at the chance though to
do it again we are waiting for the call
you know what I mean let's make it
happen people I I there are enough ABBA
songs
Judy Kramer
she is 100 on board I don't know what
the universal people are doing you are
busy so we'll wait we'll wait patiently
thank you